chicogrande des c'est le nom de cette
oeuvre que l'artiste mexicain javier
marine donne à la france
cette sculpture en bronze mesure 2,5 m
de long elle a pris place dans le jardin
du château de la celle-saint-cloud
propriété du quai d'orsay est aussi lieu
d'exposition c'est une grande fierté et
je remercie d'ailleurs le ministre
d'avoir mis en valeur touche la
dimension culturelle du domaine
l'artiste mexicain a réalisé toute une
série de sept est énorme qui sont
exposés ailleurs dans le monde
des visages inspiré d'un peuple
précolombien ou le retrouve aussi
certains traits occidentaux un concentré
d'histoire mexicaine en somme la nation
mexicaine et qui chute de ce syncrétisme
entre les cultures précolombiennes et
les cultures européennes et ses
sculptures à symbolise dans une large
mesure ce métissage des relations
diplomatiques entre la france et le
mexique battent leur plein une
exposition consacrée à l'art mexicain
s'est tenue récemment au grand palais et
la france sera bientôt l'invité
d'honneur d'un festival d'art vivant au
mexique
je pense que c'est une manière de
rapprocher les peuples elle nous sommes
dans une période tellement incertaine
que et dangereuse qu'il est important de
rapprocher les peuples et tout ce qui
peut y contribuer comme cet événement
d'aujourd'hui pas dans la bonne
direction pour découvrir l'oeuvre le
public devra attendre le 18 avril
prochain où les journées européennes du
patrimoine